let's say we want to copy this angle
right here okay so what we're gonna do
is first we're going to draw a line
segment like so we're going to draw a
point on that line segment okay this is
going to be the vertex of the angle and
what we're going to do is we're going to
go back over to the original angle this
one here on the left and what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to draw an arc so we're
gonna draw an arc like this okay and
keeping the compass in the same you know
opening same level of opening we're
going to copy that angle over here onto
onto this angle okay so okay so now
we've copied this arc and this arc now
what we're going to do is we're going to
use the compass as a measuring tool so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
over here to the original angle I'm
going to measure this distance from this
interception intersection point to this
intersection point so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to place the compass on
this okay point and I'm gonna open it so
it just reaches like so and I make a
little notation that I measured that and
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to go
over here to this angle I'm gonna do the
same thing I'm going to copy that
distance like so okay so now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna Center section
point to draw another ray and we will
have copied the angle so let me see if I
can do that accurately here for you
okay so there you can see you can
measure this with your protractor but
this angle is going to be the same
number of degrees as this angle and
you've successfully copied the angle so
go ahead and review this video if you
need to to do so otherwise all I'll see
you in the next video